hora de la información económica en
directo América de France 24 por ello me
acompaña en el estudio mi compañera
Daniela Blandón Daniela bienvenida vamos
a empezar en Chile porque el gobierno
acordó un alza en el salario mínimo Así
es Valentina el Ministerio de trabajo y
previsión social reveló que llegó a un
acuerdo con los sindicatos representados
en la central unitaria de trabajadores
para subir el salario de los 410 mil
pesos chilenos actuales que equivalen a
unos 512 dólares a precio de hoy pero el
aumento sería gradual comenzaría en mayo
hasta lo equivalente a 550 dólares
después en septiembre subiría 575 hasta
llegar a 624 dólares en junio de 2024
vale la pena aclarar que el acuerdo
todavía no está en firme debe ser
presentado al congreso para su
aprobación y posterior implementación Y
llega también una semana después de que
el congreso aprobara reducir la semana
laboral 45 a 40 a 40 horas Bueno una
reducción progresiva progresiva que se
dará Durante los próximos cinco años y
usted estuvo en Chile hace hace poco
Daniela para que alcanzamos un salario
mínimo en Chile Valentina pues
específicamente no sé para qué puede
alcanzar un salario mínimo en Chile lo
que sí le puedo decir es que este es un
país bastante costoso inclusive los
mismos turistas
se atreven a decir que es de los países
más costosos en la región y mi tarjeta
de crédito lo comprueba Daniela vamos a
cambiar de tema el ministro de
exteriores ruso ya sabemos que Lula
estuvo en Rusia hace poco ahora es el
ministro de exteriores rusos
sergueilabroft el que está en Brasil Qué
temas económicos se han abordado pues
durante esta reunión en Brasilia y su
homólogo brasileño Mauricio o Mauro
vieira dijeron haber discutido planes
para impulsar las exportaciones de carne
a Rusia y para asegurar de fertilizantes
para los agricultores brasileños después
de que la guerra en Ucrania hubiera
impactado los envíos de este insumo en
uno de los países que más produce
alimentos del mundo que es Brasil
reafirmamos nuestro enfoque en
desarrollar nuestra asociación
estratégica en todas las áreas prestamos
especial atención a la cooperación
comercial y económica la cooperación de
inversión donde se alcanzó un nivel
récord el año pasado superando los 8 mil
millones de dólares y esto está lejos
del límite y hoy hablamos sobre las
áreas que deben desarrollarse en interés
de nuestros países y nuestros ciudadanos
eso es energía y por supuesto el uso
Pacífico de la energía atómica
Daniela usted qué celular tiene un
iPhone 7 y no me da pena decir un iPhone
7 Bueno y usted sabía que Apple es una
frase conocida que los usuarios de
iPhone están enamorados de sus iPhone lo
único que le puedo decir es cuando un
que cuando uno pasa a iPhone no se
devuelve a ningún otro no se
pues Apple está expandiendo sus dominios
abre su primera tienda física en India
Claro que sí lo hará Este martes pero
exhibió antes una muestra para
periodistas y blogueros este lunes de lo
que será esta tienda minorista ubicada
en un lujoso centro comercial de mumbai
en el occidente oeste del país ya en
2020 esa empresa había lanzado una
tienda minorista en línea en esta nación
que acaba de superar a China como la más
poblada del mundo y en el que Apple
apenas tiene una participación del 3% en
el mercado de teléfonos inteligentes
debido a sus altos precios que este es
un problema es muy bueno pero sus
precios son muy altos en comparación con
sus competidores pues estaremos viendo
cómo le va a apple en India en otras
noticias Daniela los libretistas de
Hollywood podrían ir a huelga a partir
de cuándo bueno Ellos están aglutinados
en el writers América que es el
sindicato Pues que los está
representando en la pelea ellos
aprobaron por mayoría permitir que se
convoque a una huelga a partir del
primero de mayo esto sino consiguen que
compañías como Netflix y Walt Disney
entre otras les mejoren sus condiciones
los escritores y libretistas de las
grandes series y películas que usted y
yo vemos todos los días todos los días
se quejan porque los bajos salarios no
les alcanzan y porque han visto que se
están afectando por el Boom de la
transmisión por streaming por qué porque
esto ofrece producciones más cortas y
pues por supuesto los trabajos son por
menos tiempo algunos inclusive dicen que
han tenido que conseguir un trabajo
adicional el cese de actividades podría
afectar entonces las producciones que la
industria le ofrece a millones de
televidentes en el mundo vale a notar
que la última vez que los escritores de
libretos en Hollywood realizaron una
huelga fue en 2008 100 días duraron en
cese y esto dejó pérdidas millonarias
para la industria cinematográfica
Daniela cerramos con Los indicadores
económicos de la
positivo al iniciar una semana en la que
los resultados financieros de las
grandes corporaciones serán
protagonistas en América Latina las
bolsas cerraron mixtas con Argentina
subiendo más del 2% Hay que decir que
allí el dólar en el mercado informal
subió a un nuevo récord de 408 pesos y
en Europa las bolsas cerraron dispares
en París se destaca el alza de más del
1% en la acción de airbag y del 2% de
Air France después de que el fallo de la
justicia los absorbiera de absorbiera de
toda responsabilidad sobre la caída de
un avión con 228 pasajeros a bordo Hace
13 años una noticia que generó bastante
frustración en las víctimas en los
familiares de los fallecidos Daniela
usted muchas gracias por esta ampliación
económica la invito a que continúe con
nosotros que ya Seguimos aquí en directo
América con directo a